[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers ich bin andreasson er selber
heeressportler behinderten schwimmer und
ich freue mich dass ich hier im sport
report die geschichten die menschen die
persönlichkeiten hinter den über 450
harris sportlerinnen und sportlern im
österreichischen bundesheer davon 20 mit
behinderung euch näher bringen darf der
ersten erfolge freue ich mich dass wir
das österreichische erfolgreiche säge
team bestehend aus zugführer thomas
zajac und frau korporal barbara watz
herzlich willkommen freut mich dass hier
herr gefunden hat sie hat jetzt ja erst
vor kurzem sozusagen den restart nach
der komplizierten corona zeit mit der
heim-europameisterschaft thomas wie es
euch da gegangen
ja genau also wir wir durften gott sei
dank schon ab juni trainieren und unser
erster wettkampf war eigentlich vor der
ehe
das war die kieler woche und die
europameisterschaft unser zweites und
letztes event vorerst
während die kieler woche wirklich sehr
gut gelaufen ist aber leider bei der
europameisterschaft ziemlich gepatzt
es waren dieselben gegner da aber ja wie
gesagt es kann nicht immer gut gehen und
in dem fall ist es nicht gut gegangen
aber was ist genau gewesen ja ich habe
einfach genial ist nicht zusammengepasst
und zufrieden wieder ins bild die starts
war nicht gut die manöver ist es hat
alles irgendwie nicht zusammen gepasst
aber wir wissen jetzt vornamen
trainieren müssen und schauen dass man
nächstes jahr dann gestärkt sind also
auf jeden fall erkenntnisse mitgenommen
auch aus diesen dingen vermeintlichen
niederlagen gelernt da muss es eine
offene europameisterschaft das heißt
eure konkurrenten in von der ganzen welt
wann auch da vor allem bei wenigen
möglichkeiten dass man jetzt irgendwie
segelt kann man da auch schon irgendwie
abschätzen welche richtung jetzt siege
sport ein jahr vor tokio sich bewegt
naja also natürlich jeder hat probiert
diesen wettkampf mit zu nehmen wir haben
nur sehr wenige wettkämpfe es haben sich
viel mehr angemeldet als tatsächlich
gekommen sind
sie wollten kollegen aus brasilien aus
ozeanien also australien neuseeland
kommen die waren alle auf der meldeliste
haben es aber den weg nicht nach
österreich geschafft segelsport ist ein
sehr aufwendiger sport was die logistik
betrifft viele leute punkten ihre boote
in barcelona die über zehn nationen
dadurch dass es mit spanien eine
schwierige situation ist kommen sie
leider nicht kommen
nichtsdestotrotz ja wir haben nur sehr
begrenzt wettkämpfe warum weil unsere
wettkämpfe meistens in südlichen ländern
sind die sich momentan sowieso schwer
tun am meer und ergebnis einer
weltsportart das heißt wir haben sehr
sehr viele nation allein bei der
europameisterschaft war habe ich über 40
nationen am start
und man möchte jetzt auch nicht
wettkämpfe veranstalten wo man mit
anderen nationen nicht die chance gibt
daran teilzunehmen das würde vielleicht
eine wettbewerbsverzerrung in richtung
tokio geben von dem her ist jetzt einmal
viel training angesagt viele
trainingslager und wir versuchen aber
trotzdem mit internationaler beteiligung
zu trainieren um eben ein bisserl
wettkämpfe zu simulieren aber es ist das
gleiche aber auch wenn man im training
zwar mit anderen trainieren kann aber
sie nicht wirklich am wasser sein sowie
im rennen messen kann es schon ein
bisschen anders anderer flair
aber wir haben eine sehr gute
trainingsgruppe ich glaube in unserer
gruppe mit den bieten argentinien und
italienern die waren jetzt am protest
bis man das für sein hohes niveau ist
und wir können mit ihnen uns messen
und das gibt schon man weiß dass da wenn
was weitergeht dass man auf gutem niveau
sehen kann
du bist eine sehr junge sportlerin ist
auch erst seit der neue konstellation
seitdem der thomas umgestiegen ist und
sein neues team in dem sie aufgebaut hat
in dieser konstellation dabei und ist
jetzt gleich vor den olympischen spielen
mit sowas konfrontierte gehst du damit
um wie wie findest du
lösungen und wie schaffst das du
trotzdem so dran bleibt ja ich war für
mich eigentlich
ich hab's einfach akzeptiert da lockt
dann okay wir können jetzt nicht sagen
ihr habt mein training fortgeführt zu
hause so gut wie es geht und habe das
eigentlich mit einer lockerheit
angenommen und einfach ich kann ja eh
nix ändern somit habe das so angegangen
und für mich waren das eigentlich okay
ein jahr länger ein jahr länger zum
trainieren ein jahr länger zum wachsen
zum dazulernen kann gut sein für uns so
was du hast du schon ein bisschen mehr
routine jetzt nachgegangen wäre jetzt
lieber wie hast du die situation
angenommen ist das alles klar war damals
wie die dinge von einem tag auf den
anderen in dem sie eine kaputt gegangen
sind sofort aus einem trainingslager
nach österreich fast schon gefürchtet
und habt euch dann hier in quarantäne
begeben
wie ist es dir damals gegangen und wie
ist jetzt mit dem ganzen um der erstmal
wir waren gerade auf mallorca wir sind
aus australien zu bekommen
neuseeland war wurde vor und haben uns
auf die europa saison vorbereitet wir
hatten unser ganzes olympia material
dort vor ort um quasi zu entscheiden was
wir dann letzten endes nach tokio
verschiffen und sind davon ausgegangen
dass wir quasi den europa cup segeln
dass die bringt so viel drauf und das
kam dann schon das war schon sehr
surreal okay man hat gewusst
es gibt diesen virus aber wir sind
eigentlich voll davon ausgegangen dass
man trotzdem in diesen wettkampf segeln
können und das ist dann von heute auf
morgen geändert wir packen wir dazu
unsere sachen und müssen so schnell wie
möglich nach hause kommen weil wir auch
vielleicht unser material gar nimmer von
der insel bekommen
das heißt wir sind dann haben die
fairrank normen sind durch spanien
frankreich schweiz deutschland
österreich heim gefahren und mussten uns
erst einmal ein punkt kommt für zwei
wochen
ja es ist schwierig weil seine olympia
kampagne ist extrem zeitintensiv also
extrem saugt extrem viel energie auf es
ist ja nicht so dass wir uns drei vier
monate für die olympischen spiele
vorbereiten sondern wirklich vier
folgejahre wir haben auch sehr viel zeit
in tokio verbracht und auch das jetzt
auszudehnen auf fünf jahre eine olympia
kampagne ist gar nicht so ohne also da
muss man dann schon gut einteilen gut
planen
es sind auch finanzielle maßnahmen
müssen jetzt getroffen werden weil wir
natürlich nur vier jahre ausfinanziert
wollen oder eigentlich sind wir aus
finanzieren als das nur bis zur hälfte
aus finanziert und schauen dann wie man
wie man quasi auf einem guten niveau
arbeiten können also erstellt einen
sportler oder vor allem uns als segler
schon vor großen herausforderungen
gerade was das reisen betrifft aber ja
wie die babsi gesagt hat ich glaube wir
müssen einfach flexibel sein wenn man
kann natürlich immer das schlechteste
aus einer situation heraus nehmen oder
man probiert das beste aus seiner
situation zu machen und ich glaube das
ist auch das was letzten endes einen
guten sportler aus macht dass man
probleme löst mit problemen umgeht und
das maximum darauf daraus wurde das
jetzt die schwierigkeiten angesprochen
vor allem logistisch stelle ich mir das
ja alles wahnsinnig kompliziert es nicht
nur ein brot sondern mehrere boote und
die müssen ja irgendwie dauern
strategisch platziert sein damit man
halt immer gut trainieren kann wenn man
irgendwo hinkommt wo sind eure boote
gerade und wohin werden sie noch
überrascht damit ihr euch in richtung
tokio auch gut vorbereiten können
zurzeit warten bereits gespannt auf
unser material von tokio weil wir haben
alle schon bereich gehabt dass man
eigentlich nach palma also nach ostern
dann nach japan fliegen und da
trainieren
wir hatten nur mal hinfliegen und in
container aufmachen müssen jetzt kommt
das ganze material zurück auch unser
gutes material
damit man weiter material testen können
in europa und die anderen boote mir
unglaublich insgesamt vier boote sind
jetzt zurzeit alle gott sei dank in
österreich die restlichen drei zusammen
was eigentlich ganz normal ist für uns
weil normalerweise sind sie überall
verstreut
also ich sehr viel zeit zu hause
eigentlich man hat wir haben es leider
nicht so leicht dass man unser boot und
sonst einfach in die tasche packen und
ins flugzeug anpacken sondern wir müssen
wirklich schon monate davor einen
container checken container routen es
ist ja auch so wenn wenn du etwas
verschiebt egal wohin auf die welt dann
dann muss sie auf suchen okay wie kommt
diesmal von von österreich zu einer
fähre oder zu einem zu einem schiff
welche route wählst du dann überhaupt
oft versuchen wir die kürzeste oder
schnellste route zu nehmen was ein
teurer ist aber es kann passieren dass
das schiff das von hamburg zum beispiel
das boot nach miami bringt vielleicht in
england stehen bleibt dort soll probleme
hat oder es kommt ein sturm dann kann
sein dass man in miami eine woche auf
unser boot warten weil wir müssen oft
vor ort dort sein wenn der container
ankommt weil wir das aus aus dem zoll
quasi rausnehmen müssen mit den
zollbeamten gemeinsam den container
durchgehen dass man nichts geschmuggelt
haben zum beispiel wo wir in neuseeland
waren geht sondern ein kleiner dackel
durch ein container und schaut was man
eh keine blätter eingepackt haben wenn
wir zum beispiel im ende september wenn
es schon herbst in wien den container
ein button
und da kommt ein blatt von einem baum
weil man nicht aufgepasst haben
das ist ein riesiger als und 40 fuß
container da passt vielzahl dran und
dann findet dieser tage dieses blatt vom
baum dann wird der container erstmal in
quarantäne wies das labor gesehen hat
dass auf diesem blatt kenne keine
bakterien darauf sind die ökosysteme
dort irgendwie gefährden das heißt ja
das alles ist ein riesiger logistischer
aufwand
das hat nach seiner karriere im
segelsport kann man wahrscheinlich eine
speditionsfirma aufmachen und hat alles
know how das notwendig ist um
auf dem markt erfolgreich zu sein nur
damit man sich ungefähr eine dimension
vorstellen kann jetzt segelt seiner
bootsklassen accra 17 unserem boot
kostet wahnsinnig viel in welchen
dimensionen sind so die buskosten aber
wir rechnen mit 40.000 euro brutto ca
mit dem gesamten material müssen
bekommen ja das boot und bauen ist ja
mal eine woche aus damit man unsere
eigenen systeme unserer eigenen kleinen
weil jeder hat zerbissen kann man hat
ein bisschen spielraum und jeder hat
sachen lieber der animax oder andere so
somit bei uns mal sachen aus und dann
haben wir sind nicht viel ersatzmaterial
falls was passiert falls mal was kaputt
machen weil es kann schon sein dass mein
wo dagegen fliegt doch mal was verbiegt
das sollte ja nicht so oft vorkamen
es kann schnell passieren weil das
nämlich sehr schnell ist was ihr macht
thomas wie schnell bewegt sich dann was
an was macht die nagra 17 klasse denn so
besonders genau also wissen makler 17
das ist ein katamaran es ist die
schnellste olympische bootsklasse und
wir segeln auf so genannten fonds das
sind flügel wenn man so will die im
wasser drinnen sind und das gesamte bot
bloß uns mannschaft aus dem boden raus
hebt und uns bis zu dreifache
windgeschwindigkeit fahren lässt also
ich weiß ein podcast aber die per video
zu schauen man sieht man sieht ein
bisserl auf dem foto hier im studio bzw
kann man es auch google haben coole
youtube-videos wenn das ein gibt keine
werbung
und ja das dass das boot wird schon
wahnsinnig schnell und es passieren auch
immer wieder schlimme unfälle leider
aufgrund der hohen geschwindigkeiten
wir fahren ja nicht alleine über das
gewässer sondern wir fahren meistens
gegen 60 70 80 andere boote und da kann
schon mal passieren dass es da einen
kleinen crash gibt oder zum beispiel bei
hoher welle dass wir uns überschlagen
und dann muss man schauen was das doch
keine schweren verletzungen heraus
kommen das hat in der vergangenheit
leider welche gegeben es hat ein
amerikaner vier finger verloren und
laden tiefe schnittwunden gehabt
letztes jahr in tokio das seitenband
gerissen also wenn man unsere olympia
kampagne am markt 17 verletzungsfrei
über steht dann hat man viel erreicht
das heißt nicht nur logistisch viel
gelernt sondern auch hart im nehmen
bewiesen dass man darüber schauen metall
also wirklich in vielen domänen
fertigkeiten
jetzt stehe ich natürlich frage
österreich hat er schon seit vielen
jahren keinen meeres zugang mehr wie
kommt man in österreich zum segelsport
ich mal bei dirk ist dass wir in der
familie thomas du hast da wahrscheinlich
den segelsport schon in die wiege gelegt
bekommen wie war das bedingt aber genau
also mein vater war schon 1980 bei den
olympischen spielen den segeln
und wenn du an sega bist dann danach so
dass meistens nicht nur zu sportlichen
zwecken sondern du bist einfach ein
segler du lebst das und genauso war dass
wir mit meinem vater also wir hatten
schon wo ich ganz gern war hatten wir so
segeltörns urlauber und mit im alter von
sechs jahren und sieben jahren bin ich
dann in den optimisten reingekommen das
ist eine kleine schale mit zehn kinder
segeln lernen was übrigens eine mega
gala ausbildung für jeden jungen
menschen ist hallo als 67 jähriger dass
du kein auto lenken aber ein segelboot
lenken und sitzt alleine und und lernst
mit den elementen umzugehen mit wasser
mit windows keinen motor musste mal
herausfinden von wo kommt der wind muss
alleine von a nach b kommen und dann
hast du keine eltern die da draußen am
wasser sind und die helfen sondern muss
alleine das problem lösen und
spielerisch und es war schon schon cool
als kind wenn man wenn man die
möglichkeit hat zu was zu erlernen
das bei dir auch so dass in der
nussschale angefangen hat barbara oder
man hat es einen anderen bezug und weg
meine eltern nicht segler also die keine
essentiellen überhaupt nicht aus ich
habe in der nussschale gelernt in seiner
eine volksschule in eine woche
sportwoche eigentlich und da hat es mich
so fasziniert dass exakt im markt in
sport erlernen und weitermachen und bin
dann in eine sportschule mit dem
schwerpunkt segeln gegangen und dort hat
mir dann eigentlich den trainer entdeckt
und hat mir dann eher zum regatten see
gebracht und dann blieben und das ziel
ist ja auch nach dem du deine ich hatte
ja schon veredelt hast mit edelmetall
bei den olympischen spielen
was kann man da so erwarten von euch als
neues team sag jetzt mal unter
anführungszeichen gesetzt schon einige
jahre zusammen aber in richtung tokio
gibt es da zielsetzungen die euch
vornimmt oder haltet sie das sehr low
level als sportler hat man immer
zielsetzungen
die frage ist nur wie man es definiert
wir versuchen halt unsere ziele nicht
zwangsläufig über platzierungen zu
definieren sondern über leistung über
performance
ich glaube wenn wir quasi unsere ziele
erreichen das was wir uns vornehmen dann
kommt die platzierung von alleine am
ende des tages
ich glaube es ist immer wichtig wenn du
zu einem großen wettkampf fast dass du
dir danach selbst in die augen schauen
kannst und sagen kannst okay du hast
dann passt es probiert wurst fehler
werden passieren weil unser wettkampf
dauert eine woche bei unterschiedlichen
bedingungen jeder macht fehler
am ende gewinnt wer die wenigsten fehler
gemacht hat auch in rio bei den
olympischen spielen waren nur einen
punkt zu gold und punktegleich mit
silber und in so vielen worten sind mehr
fehler passiert aber wie gesagt das ist
irgendwie lauf der natur dass das normal
ist und wir müssen einfach gut arbeiten
wir investieren wirklich über 250 tage
im jahr im amt zu sein um zu trainieren
und ich glaube ja wenn man das alles
umsetzen was wir uns vorgenommen haben
dann wenn am ende des tages hoffentlich
auch um edelmetall mitkämpfen können in
tokio und all das was du jetzt
geschildert dass das ist auch die vielen
tage unterwegs und die den ganzen
aufwand den wir betreiben muss das geht
natürlich nicht ohne unterstützung im
rücken bauer dieser zeit
deine schuld seite direkt ins bundesheer
gekommen und bis jetzt herthas
sportlerin gemeinsam im thomas im team
welche rolle spielt so was als junge
athletin dass man die möglichkeit hat
sich als der sportler komplett dem sport
widmen zu können ohne irgendwie urlaub
nehmen und nebenbei arbeiten gehen und
all diese dinge die man sonst in einem
normalen jungen erwachsenenalter alles
bedenken müsste ja es ist ganz wichtig
also ich glaube ohne die bundeswehr hat
man hätte diese karriere oder segeln gar
nicht so machen können
das so intensiv diesen weg einschlagen
können ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie da
eigentlich nach der matur gekommen bin
und das mal versichert sind wir uns
eigentlich um nichts sorgen müssen
und unseren sport einfach betreiben
können deine mutter ist schon länger her
zu machen
aber du hast du glaub ich 25 war es noch
ein jüngeres für den segelsport auf
jeden fall und hast du auf jeden fall
jetzt auch was für den kopf stellen
weiterhin getan
während deiner karriere auch schon an
die zukunft denken hast studiert auch da
waren wir studienkollegen
wie war das für dich und ist auch vom
bundes handys ermöglicht worden
die finanzierung des studiums welchen
stellenwert hat das dass man auch
wirklich einmal sagen kann ich habe was
in der hand sollte wieder mal was
passieren verletzungen kommen oder sich
irgendetwas tun und man muss vielleicht
die karriere beenden
erstens einmal finde ich als junger
sportler ist schon was besonderes wenn
man beim bundesheer einkommen ich kann
mich erinnern in meiner schulzeit
es waren die älteren segler die quasi
schon fertig war mit der schule die beim
bundesheer waren zu denen habe ich immer
aufgeschaut das war so ein großes ziel
von mir da rein zu kommen weil ich
gewusst habe okay es gibt nicht viele
chancen in so sportarten wie segeln die
zwar auf der einen seite sehr
erfolgreich sind
das ist die folge sind da aber der film
fehlt ein bisschen der öffentliche das
heißt man macht sich auch keine
illusionen als junger mensch
man wird von sponsorgeldern einfach
nicht leben können das heißt man braucht
eine art förderung und
das bundesheer ist halt fast einmaliger
die wieder solche sportarten fördert und
viele erfolge gerade aus solchen sparten
wie segeln und andere sparten würden
einfach nicht geben ohne den bundesheer
und und das muss ich als junger menschen
ich habe mich erinnern ich war 16 17 mal
sogar überlegt aber nicht die ergebnisse
nicht bringt bis zu meiner matura dann
komme ich vielleicht nicht ins in den
herzsport rein
vielleicht sollte ich einfach durch
flinke in der schule wirklich eine
einheit die ergebnisse zu bringen
ja das war echt das waren meine gedanken
damals gott sei dank hatte ich kurz vor
der matura wirklich gute erfolge schon
in herr sport angekommen das hat man
letzteres ermöglicht überhaupt den
leistungssport so so zu machen wie wir's
machen weil anders geht es nicht du
kannst nicht nebenbei arbeiten und
versuchen international erfolge zu
bekommen gegen andere nationen die das
vollzeit machen und das stimmt es ist
nicht nur das das man angestellt ist und
versichert ist und seinen sport wirklich
zu 100 prozent sich auf seinen sport
fokussieren kann sondern es gibt halt
auch eine einer zeit nach nach der
sportlichen karriere
und da hat man das bundesheer ihm auch
ermöglicht eben bundeswehr den
ausbildungs kontingent und und das habe
ich schon wahrgenommen wie waren im
studienkollegen ist ein bisschen länger
gebraucht davon da glaube ich auch
[Gelächter]
und ja das ist das ist schon das ist
schon etwas wo auch andere nationen
sagen so bisschen eifersüchtig in unsere
richtung schauen
die fragen sich nämlich wie kann
österreich so erfolgreich sein in im
segelsport wo wir ja überhaupt kein mehr
zugang haben aber es hängt auch schon
von den rahmenbedingungen ab die wir
haben aber die frage nämlich gleich an
und was denkst du warum ist österreich
so eine segel nation obwohl wir in dem
sie eigentlich nicht prädestiniert sind
eine segel nation zu sein
viele sehen und auf denen wird immer
fleißig zählt und ich glaub das ist doch
sind nicht die einfachsten reviere wie
man gesehen hat also bei der
europameisterschaft sind auch viele
kommen und das gibt es nicht
so was habe ich noch nie gesehen und so
was habe ich noch nie erlebt dass der
wind bei unserer bis landes drehen kann
wer mehr da haben schon einige probleme
damit gehabt
und leider haben wir nur flachwasser
aber ich glaube es gibt eine sehr gute
jugendarbeit und da war so sehr viel
engagement von den leuten die sie
begeistern wir sehen dass da einfach
immer gute leute rauskommen und leute
dass intensiver machen wollen dass mit
diesen bedingungen kann man nur
erfolgreich sein im segelsport
jetzt hat so was schon ein bisschen
anklingen lassen die zukunft wenn du ein
bisschen so in die zukunft ausbauen
wohin wird bei dir gehen nach dem segeln
irgendwann einmal in vielen vielen
jahren hätte ich bin jetzt einmal im
hier und jetzt
die haben gar keine gedanken über die
zukunft gemacht bin da in dieser saison
ein bisschen rein gerutscht
jetzt genieße ich einmal ich bin noch
jung haben derzeit und überlegt man das
ein bisschen später gemacht zu einem
erlebnis aus deinem leben wodurch
gemerkt hast das ist auch relativ
schnell in eine ganz andere richtung
gehen kann da hat es nämlich einen
schweren unfall wo du dich schwer
verletzt hast du 2009 soweit ich das
weiß ist natürlich für mich auch ein
bezug weil ich viele freunde habe die
ähnliche unfälle hatten bei denen
daneben eine bleibende behinderung als
als resultat hervor geschaut hat und für
mich als behindertensportler ist das
natürlich auch ein thema das ich sehr
aktuell finde wie es dir damals gegangen
und wenn du jetzt zum beispiel schaust
dass es auch behinderten sportler gibt
die den sport als herr sportler
ausführen können welchen blick hast du
auf dieses thema wie also damals beim an
unfall war so dass ich eben abschnitts
bin beim klettern und ich haben ja
mehrere wirbel gebrochen und beide und
ich habe
lange auch eine zeit lang meine beine
nicht spielen können einer der ersten
der mich besucht hat war dass wenn
reiger behindertensportler war in der
leichtathletik sehr erfolgreich dann
auch im segelsport und der hat gesagt
nein eigentlich haben da einige staaten
nachwuchs bei uns schon also ich glaube
schon dass das coole ist im segelsport
ich kann auch vom segelsport reden dass
fast alle unsere events bisher zusammen
waren quasi die die behinderten sportler
mit den mit den normalen segeln und das
ist ganz normal die segeln am selben
gewässer die sägen im selben wind und
wir lernen voneinander und also ich
glaube das ist einfach ein wichtiger
teil ist um auch zu zeigen dass wenn wir
mal was passiert ist oder wenn du mit
einem nachteil auf die welt gekommen
bist dass du um nichts unfähiger bist
als als ein mensch der halt glück gehabt
hat er in dem sinne von dem hut ab von
von allen die die trotz handicap
verletzt endes ist es ein handicap
gegenüber anderen trotzdem dieselbe
leistung oder vielleicht noch mehr
leistung erbringen in relation
ich glaube da kann man sich sehr viel
davon auch schon da kann ich dir nur
zustimmen und ich glaube ich hab's auch
beide bewiesen dass wir das selbst als
astrid gesagt hast auch in eure karriere
eingesetzt habe es nämlich widrige
umstände trotzdem zum guten nutzen und
trotzdem das beste daraus machen
österreich ohne meerzugang und trotzdem
sei eine der erfolgreichsten segel
dienst der welt und hat vieles gelernt
aus dem segelsport herzlichen dank dass
ihr heute beim sport rapport da war bei
mir wünsche euch alles gute für die
zukunft hoffentlich klappt alles auf dem
weg nach tokio hoffentlich kommen die
boote immer rechtzeitig überall an und
hoffe dass sie gesund und
verletzungsfrei bleibt danke euch ja das
war es mit der ersten folge des
sportwarts dem sport podcast des
österreichischen bundesheers wir freuen
uns wenn ihr auch bei den nächsten
malen immer mit dabei sein und ganz
viele spannende persönlichkeit menschen
und geschichten hinter den harris
sportlerinnen und sportlern
kennenlernens bis dann servus